so the other day i got a text from a
friend asking me if i had seen disney's
latest villain origin story cruella
now i had this movie on my watch list
i've been a big fan of emma stone since
super bad so i thought doing a video on
it would be an easy a
but my friend also told me about all
these claims that cruella is a rip-off
of todd phillips 2019 film
joker and i was like just how much in
common can a disney movie have with an
r-rated film that the media feared would
actually spark a string of mass
shootings so i did the scariest thing to
come out of all this which is pay 30
bucks to rent cruella
and see just how similar these two films
are i'm gonna present you with the
evidence so you can make up your own
mind is cruella just like the joker or
is this
awesome kind of joke is this some kind
of joke but before we get into it
make sure to like and subscribe i come
out with all sorts of ending explained
in comparison videos plus i
really just need to make back that 30
bucks spoilers for joker and cruella
ahead before we get into how
both these characters are similar it's
important to look at these films
aesthetically both take place
predominantly in crime-ridden
metropolitan cities london and gotham
but it's not just the place
it's the time cruella is set in 1977 as
found in cruella's acceptance letter
when she gets her first job
joker doesn't have an exact date but
according to indiewire it's around the
late 1970s to early 1980s
and the costume design of the time match
in both films with a 70s aesthetic even
the colors are predominantly desaturated
with an emphasis
on browns dark greens and muted tones
both films were
shot with the same camera in ahri alexa
use the same film lab company 3 in los
angeles and have run times around the 2
hour mark but even the music is
similar both utilize pieces from the
time period and in one case even the
same song
[Music]
the characters themselves are where the
films really start to show off their
similarities even the titles of each
film are named after the characters
alter egos corella's real name is
estella and over the course of the film
she becomes
cruella joker's real name is arthur
fleck and over the course
of that film he becomes joker both
characters experience a descent into
madness that is brought upon by both
society
and their relationships with their
family specifically their mothers
joker's mother abandoned him as a child
and penny who was a nurse at arkham
asylum
took him in and hid this secret from him
similarly cruella was abandoned by
her real mother the baroness and raised
by one of the baroness's maids
a secret which is also held from her in
effect both characters were orphaned
they have mothers who abandon them and
this
abandonment affects them psychologically
it has caused them immense
pain i know you're in pain and i know
that she caused it
when arthur finds out that penny isn't
his real mother and has been using him
to extort thomas wayne
he kills her by smothering her with a
pillow when cruella finds out that the
baroness is her real mother she devises
a way to get rid of her in a more
disney fashion by getting her imprisoned
each character starts down and out and
over the course of their respective
journeys transforms them into their
alter egos
the first scene of the joker is him
working as a clown ridiculed and beat up
by some hooligans
cruella starts off in similar fashion
having to scrub floors toilets and
ridiculed by her boss
just like joker's boss and co-workers
both characters
end up getting fired both of them are
also criminals joker a serial murderer
and
obviously you can't make cruella that in
a disney movie so they make her a thief
but as cruella becomes
more and more sinister just like joker
gets more and more violent cruella does
consider
murder an option killing her is not
gonna make that go away
i won't unless i really really have to
as her character grows we aren't quite
sure whether cruella is joking anymore
about the violent things she says
they really would make fabulous coats
the dogs or here's one of my favorites
and she's a homicidal maniac and you're
not
we don't know that yet i'm still young
just like how the joker embraces his
alter ego so too does cruella
and even society in joker arthur's
actions lead him to become a symbol
raging against the establishment the
same is true in cruella where as the
baroness symbolizes the establishment
cruella represents a new vanguard trying
to seize control by any means necessary
and joker is seen by some as a hero
and others as a villain just like
cruella is seen as a designer by some
and a vandal by others heck they even
say this outright in the film
some call her a designer
both characters embrace being symbols
joker at the very end as he's embraced
by the rioters and cruella as she's
recruiting for her
final heist but people do need a villain
to believe in so i'm happy to fit the
bill
the rift between upper and lower class
is paralleled in each film as well take
a look at the poverty-filled world of
arthur and estella
in comparison to the luxury of thomas
wayne and the baroness
each character has to suppress their
submissive sides in order for their
alter ego to fully manifest arthur is a
total pushover but
joker is an alpha estella is a pushover
and cruella is an alpha
cruella gets things done stella does not
as we reach the end of cruella just like
what happens near the end in joker our
characters
fully embrace these egos
[Music]
one small thing yeah when you bring me
out
can you introduce me as joker listen to
these lines in cruella which could
easily suit the joker
mustache much to avenge revenge and
destroy
gorilla and joker are also similar in
their chosen career paths
both are struggling artists arthur a
stand-up comic and estella an emerging
fashion designer both of them keep
notepads arthur ford's jokes and estella
for her designs the difference here is
that arthur really doesn't have any
talent
but don't tell them i said that each of
them have another person in their
industry they're obsessed with albeit
for different reasons arthur loves the
comedian late night host murray and even
fantasizes about being on his show
a fantasy that comes to reality in the
film's bloody climax
estella is obsessed with the baroness
eventually landing a job as a designer
assistant she has a whole wall filled
with news about her and her designs
even the climax of the films are similar
when you think about it both involve a
tragic incident involving the main
characters with an
audience watching in joker it's on
murray's live show in cruella it's at
her estate with all the party guests
watching
and yes both characters evade the police
over the course of their respective
films
in cruella in order to fit in she has
managed to get all the dinner guests to
dress up just like her
much like in joker when the rioters dawn
clown masks just like joker cruella and
joker also have similar looks and
mannerisms when estella turns into
cruella she dons white makeup just like
joker does the two even have their own
iconic laughs
[Laughter]
arthur is also a big smoker just like
the original cruella is in the 1961
animated movie
101 dalmatians however they took that
out because disney doesn't like to have
smoking in their movies
each film also ends up tying in to other
films in their respective franchises
leaving room for potential sequels
in joker we see young bruce wayne in the
alleyway with his
murdered parents the night of the gotham
riots in corello we see roger anita
giving dalmatian puppies as gifts
pongo and perdita respectively which is
a tie into the events of 101 dalmatians
the baroness also states that she'll be
back as she gets carted away to prison
leaving the potential for another sequel
joker is seen with bloody footprints
implying that he killed his therapist
escaping the mental institution and we
already know that a joke or two is in
the works
and just for fun we have a similarity
speed round of a bunch of things i found
similar that i couldn't quite weave into
this main narrative a shot of dying your
hair in the mirror to signify your
character changing
joker and cruella both being fashion
icons each film's reliance on newspaper
titles giving out exposition
gala events where our characters are not
allowed committing crimes on public
transit although these two films share
many similarities i gotta say they
are two different films in fact if
someone hadn't mentioned the two being
similar i probably wouldn't have even
thought twice of connecting the two but
i wanna know what you guys think in the
comments below will cruella inspire a
wave of dalmatian kidnappings or is this
all just a bunch of hot air thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
like and subscribe it really helps the
channel out and be sure to check out my
other comparison videos
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much